the great defensive tackles in the NFL
and Oklahoma sooner himself joins us how
painful was that Oklahoma Georgia game
for you Gerald for this snowstorm you
know what what's the worst weather you
ever played it I think it would be in
the big 12 championship in oh wait
against Missouri it's where you go what
was it like
Jeff snow yeah it was snow low twenties
Oh Mia teens
it was definitely snowing it wasn't like
freakish no one but it was snow do you
go out there sleeveless just to set the
tone let people know you're all business
[Laughter]
now I know that you got a bias here with
Oklahoma but if as you look at Baker
Mayfield who could you know as he could
be the opponent next year what more than
likely he'll be an opponent so how would
you look at that personality and how
would that affect you as you're playing
against him well you know as an opponent
you like he loved to compete against a
guy like Baker Baker in college if you
look at him in college who he is and how
he's been he gets pushed you in the mind
frame up completely different sized
human but Cam Newton with how much swag
he got you know how he carries himself
he respects the game but he just loved
to have a good time and he's a fierce
competitor and that's just who Baker is
and then he just puts you in that same
iframe and I compete against Cam twice a
year so I would have a little you know
familiarity was dealing with a guy like
Baker but he's just he's a great player
man but is there ever a point when you
say to Kim shut up uh no because this
game needs a guy like Cam Newton this
game needs Odell Beckham's the Richard
Sherman is the Michael Bendis you know I
guess you can say the showman's yeah we
beat this game needs it and these kids
man they need to see that you know these
guys these heroes these kids look at
each week
have worked their entire life to get to
this point and they don't realize the
effort and how much strain it takes to
get to a game day and not only get to
the game they will play on a game day
and not only play but make plays on a
game day oh I love that excited that's
right you know that's where all the
excitement and just energy come from so
the game needs guys like that and I
think it's good for these kids to see
this okay to have fun I'm and he works
your entire life to get to this level
I love the personality I just don't know
as a competitor where you just you know
when when cam does the Superman stuff
and then you you know you just want to
say something to him yeah I love to
compete against guys like can you know
guys with it that type of Swagger and
energy because when you when you take
them down or when you win against them
you know it feels that much better but
I'm just a fan of the game so it's
exciting to see my son is a huge fan of
Cam Newton and I always tell him I am to
accept what we're playing against me all
right
the team's the the Buccaneers face the
Vikings Patriots Falcons Panthers and
Saints give me the scouting report as a
defensive player as I look at Case
Keenum what is it that you want to force
Case Keenum to do um hold the ball the
case is great at getting the ball out
his hand you know even when he gets off
the spot he still could get the ball out
of his hand man you got to get case to
hold the ball and then make him think a
little bit he's a very intelligent
quarterback and he does he doesn't hold
the ball a lot he gets the ball out very
quickly so it's hard to get to him but
uh you know if you can get him to hold
the ball being you got a shot you know
but uh he just he's a you know he's got
a quick trigger and that ball is coming
up through the scouting report of what
you want Brady to do is what make it
make Brady move man when he can get
comfortable in that pocket and sit still
and just make those throws that's what
makes him you know the greatest of all
time you know he can get comfortable
when he gets in his rhythm and he's on
top he just is
you know I don't think he ever gets
flustered or loses confidence that's
what makes him who he is well when he
can get really comfortable and just sit
back there and
that sector defense need in trouble does
he talk to you
no do you talk to you I got I got the
Brady
early in the game I'm one of the sacks
that I hit him and uh you know I got up
to run off and he kind of look kind of
looked bad just hitting me
and he looked at me was like keep
bringing it put straight face and I'm
like unbothered just he was like keep
bringing it and that was it I was like
okay all right sure give me this
scouting report what do you want Matt
Ryan to do oh man you got a hit man Ryan
early man if you can hit if you can hit
Maddy ice early man then he starts to
look at the rush and when he when he
starts looking at the rush that's when
he makes those inherent throws my hand
put Maddy I smile I love Matt Ryan man
one thing he does is he's a he's a guy
who gets on the roll as well if he gets
on a roll
you know he's hard to stop and that's
why he said he's not the former MVP for
no reason it was times where he got that
play action going then he got on a roll
when he gets his rhythm he is nearly
impossible to slow down Cam Newton do
you want him to run or do you want him
to throw you won't camera throw cameras
best when he can move around
you won't canvas it in the pocket and
throw you he's incredible oh man he's
I'm a huge fan of cam but he's a big kid
when he can keep moving with his feet
with the run game and moving in the
pocket you know he getting the slider
speed and he slides his feet very well
he could step up in those open spaces
and make those throws man and he's
praying I don't know too many people in
the league who got a stronger armed in
him you know and when he when he listed
thanks lot man he can really spin it so
you got to do your best to try and make
him stand in there and just throw you
out the game he's Gerald McCoy the
Buccaneers defensive tackle Drew Brees
what do you try to get drew brees to do
yeah get pushed up the middle drew
not very tall and I teased him about
this all the time you know you see a lot
of times he's like on his tippy toes
like trying to see over the lineman so
when you get push up the middle and
that's why when I play against the
Saints a lot I do more power moves and
blue rushing because you know I can get
on the edge of the guards in this league
but with Drew you know you can get on
the edge he's gonna step up and make
those throws that's what he wants you to
do so you got to get more pressure up
the middle with a pocket push and
getting his face and then it's hard for
him to see those receivers but he's
excellent with screens and getting the
ball out and he's real crafty once you
think you got him in your hands he can
flip the ball you know he just he's
great with switching switching hands
with the ball you try and get a
saxophone well he switched his hands and
it flips it out it yeah drew is just
he's a future hall-of-famer for a reason
can you help us understand when Jameis
was eating the W with his his three
fingers like what can you help us with
this Gerald I okay not I cannot help you
understand I my quarterback is very
passionate and he does whatever he feels
necessary to get us ready for the game
and as who he is who he's gonna be and
you know we support wait you didn't even
ask like you just let him go III don't
know what it was but I was entertained
by it but I've never seen somebody give
an inspirational talk where they're
eating a W so yeah anything anything
that James does to help his teammates
just to motivate his teammates so you
know when he when he does things like
that we just look at it like he just
trying to get us ready so let's go win
this game are you gonna be healthy for
next season absolutely okay I just wanna
make sure yeah you better be I had my I
had high expectations for the Bucs man I
bought in I watched Hard Knocks I bought
in
you let me down you and the bucks let me
down Gerald I hope you're happy yeah you
know we let ourselves down we know that
uh we could have gotten much more from
this season and a lot of it man we were
three and seven and close game in one
score games and the teams were in the
playoffs right now those one score games
they found a way to come out on top such
as Caroline of the week we had the game
won and then we you know we gave them
their last driving there it is game over
that's just how common hot season went
and but we love that a coach cutter be
back we love his vision and me
personally I love my coach and I'm
excited for the future we will find a
way to finish those one score games but
that's really what it was man those we
was in tight games and didn't finish
them and we've got to find a way to make
it go out way hey it's always fun to
talk to you good luck in the offseason
and we appreciate you breaking down
these playoff quarterbacks and hopefully
you'll be in the playoffs next year
gerald that's a Gerald McCoy Buccaneers
defensive tackle for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]